[Music]
in got hot news Oh submitted by Pokemon
master Oh a Father's Day card revealed
to a woman her husband's double life
desert wind may be another another kid
sent him a hi daddy happy birthday happy
birthday Father's Day oh my god can I
live in your head for like an hour out
there I can do more than an hour why
it's a party that's why except for the
times when I start arguing Jess
oh man myself
it pretty much is because she didn't
even say nothing I don't even mean to
why she's even say that I made it up
successful [ __ ] Joe on Father's Day eat
Tuco what happened why I tell you this
though in the morning I realized that's
when we tap into the grid of collective
consciousness so I have to make sure
that once when I wake up I'm thinking of
positive thoughts and not negative
thoughts because if you open up your
Instagram and you start thinking of
things and you let that autopilot go on
that's how you go down the rabbit hole
[ __ ] so make sure you tap into the good
stuff horse thank you happen to a lot of
porn so this story is about Eddie and
Carolyn Kevin so they met on a dating
app Carolyn fell in love very quickly
they got married within a year oh she
says she never had any reason to not
trust him or you think that literally
but she's known her for a year you know
that not even a year I'm sorry less than
a year yeah they were married within a
year yeah but that's about the point
when you really want to always cream pie
[Laughter]
that's our affection okay so the dog
[ __ ] hmm the honeymoon baby yeah so
Eddie works in an oil and gas are in oil
and gas so he had a fly-in fly-out job
which meant that he was away working for
eight days and then home for six days
you with me
tried to he goes back and forth eight
six eight six yeah okay eight six
so then um she's saying like that worked
out beautifully look at yourself you
look ridiculous
it's the cream hi I just want to see
what Joe writes on his Valentine's Day I
just want to read those I don't think he
knows what Valentine's Day is February
26
oh [ __ ] you got a birthday mixed up with
Valentine July 2 that's brilliant
I love 26 no not fit you you just said a
month is a day January in the new year
everyone knows Valentine's Day is on the
29th of February dude it's on the 33rd
[Laughter]
let me help you wait 14 okay February
yes I knew it was February I just didn't
she gives it a year 2012 so that answers
the Valentine's card question that you
have it's not happening yeah so anyway
so then Caroline is saying how that
whole ordeal II worked out for her
because she liked having her own company
- and then it was nice when he was home
her own company - like her having her
companion like home Oh wealth time like
the loan type oh yeah and then she likes
to hang out with her friends at her
girlfriends a lot so anyway so then time
goes on they end up having twin
daughters then that's when life got a
little harder for her cuz she was
handling them you guys can relate you
guys have two babies yeah we're 220
dollars we do Mina connected yeah yeah
so then uh she was saying that it just
got harder because she had to do
everything on her own when he was gone
for those eight days and then uh time
went on even more oh so she told him
like hey this is getting really hard and
then he was like okay you just say the
word and I'll quit my job immediately
and I'll be all yours I'll find
something here we can do that and she
was like no it's fine I can handle it
I'm just really stressed right now so
then two more years went on oh yeah so
then let me guess
part-time daddy well because he has a
fly out a fly and six eight six yeah but
I bet when he's flying out he's meeting
his other family well having families
yeah but yeah you could he's getting
bored TIFF I know I'm getting bored -
I'm trying to remember this story this
is about my [ __ ] face hurts from
laughing too much wait wait wait but my
guess is we're correct it was it we
don't have to guess it's in the title I
don't know my birthday perfect birthday
Mother's Day card gasps no letter finish
be quiet God keep going fast-forward to
all this bullsh a if you want to read
the whole story you can read it yourself
but the point is that she finds a
Father's Day card in the
his drawer that's what I was waiting for
it was signed from like happy Father's
Day love from Nate's and then she waited
till he got home because she didn't want
to talk to him what do you put it in the
[ __ ] drawer though wall slit he
wanted to [ __ ] get caught exactly so
then when she finally confronted him
after putting the girls asleep she all
she said was whose mates really called
me whatever and then that's when he holy
his face crumbled he confessed that he
yeah that he had been with his partner
Natasha for ten years
Oh or he lived with her the time when
she yeah you guys competed yeah the one
he's six he's with her when it's eight
he's with other yeah yeah exactly so we
think you just got in like he just
started having an affair all because
then she thought Carolyn thought that
Natasha was probably the excitement
beside one but it ended up being
Caroline little Natasha was first I
would die if I was a side [ __ ] I want
to be the main [ __ ] yeah so they're
side kids twins kill the other one yeah
yeah yeah oh why would he put this much
stress on himself I know and then when
does he find time to actually work
there's so many stories like this Doha
where people have like a double life and
then they have families elsewhere that
can hang I always thought my dad had
that why I don't know I just had a
feeling I mean it's not true well you
did 23andme maybe you could find other
family members that's right I think
we're good but I for some reason I just
because I didn't would never see him not
that he was an absent father at all he
was a great dad uh but yeah I was just
like he probably has a different or he
just works really hard
that's exactly what my parents could
never have a separate family they're
both [ __ ] insane who the [ __ ] would
ever want to be with those two [ __ ]
maniacs like he's talking about us I
kind of offended a little song no
they're just so insane like I remember
like as a kid one time I had a kid I
wasn't a kid but they were just
literally fighting and they would always
say hey like I'm just leave I'm abroad
we're gonna get a divorce
I remember like I was so old at this
point I looked them I was like who the
[ __ ] would ever want to marry you too
you guys are just stuck with each other
just shut the [ __ ] up I guess so
[ __ ] mad so I stayed with each other
huh yeah I slammed the door cuz it was
late at night I go to school
Oh tired well you're so responsible so I
just Lam the door I woke up and they
just had breakfast like it was nothing
same [ __ ] just a bunch of babies just
yelling at each other I think it'll be
harder for a lady to live a double life
yeah that's the hard part
no she's really fat yeah bad bars
perspective all you gave him there yeah
cuz that's a good perspective yeah cuz I
remember I got in trouble because I
asked my teacher that what would happen
if a really fat person got pregnant how
would they know the difference was
another 60 pounds to 300 damn well you
do know the difference was she big you
do know the difference David that's so
stupid I could see what you got in
trouble no I'm just saying like being
pregnant it's not easy and it's not like
oh I mean he's not wrong there are [ __ ]
Center cases were women not as [ __ ] ton
there's not a majority that's what we
talk about I'm gonna make the news cuz
of rare fingers [ __ ] son because it was
they made a whole show around that yeah
Oh see your face it's crazy
cuz it's so odd you know I mean like if
it was the norm there'd be no show no
nice try
thanks to would be really skinny and you
were pregnant with like a [ __ ] and
then they're that small that you don't
even know like the baby small nurse Mike
do mate like do [ __ ] pregnancies those
are the same no no I think it is smaller
no he's made it a politically correct
term no it's it's a little person now
yeah you know sometimes I imagine like
if I let's say like I didn't know I
didn't know either I was just making
sure for myself cuz I can see me too too
let's see if I have kids and then I
remarry and have more kids or like or
like I'm like this dude and I have a
double life with a bunch of kids right
oh and I'm like man I can I can fast
forward to the future and see all of my
kids like Game of Thrones fighting over
my wealth I could see that did you guys
ever watch Malcolm in the Middle
yes so did you totally didn't even hear
anything
he's completely blew over about
it's Charlie Brown like all your kids
gonna [ __ ] one day grow up and fight
over your the wealth that you've made I
think most people don't think they're
gonna have kids all over the place or
your kids are gonna do a battle royale
over you do yeah I think about it a lot
no who's your double life I don't have
kids my life hey you know uh but I'm
like if I do then I'm scared that
they're not gonna be I just want them to
be a family like even if they're not a
hundred percent blood and they're
half-brothers and sisters I want them to
be like connected in work try to stay
with one person then and then you can
fill that family that's true yeah I have
a bunch of half-brothers and actually I
have a half-brother half-sister and
two-step twin brothers and one real
younger sister by law and we're like six
different types of breeds but you guys
are all yeah we're hella close you're
tight though we're mad
you guys gonna fight over like no I want
the pot like what wasn't parents
thinking because there's like my mom
with him had a good time
obviously there's so many different
types so you bond over it from your mom
uh no not the step but the it's like a
weird situation but it's great like we
have a blast to go see that's what I
want if I do have I'll be you want me as
your kid you're you're awesome do not be
dumb all right so father said I can't
believe I just witnessed it they know
fight for your wolf that's how it
happened know the ending to this story
though I get a feature game on your
YouTube channel shut him out yes dead
yes a new Prince is born in the kingdom
of Jamali
wait but I wanted to yeah what is it
what is it what is it so Caroline so
obviously we broke up yeah they broke up
and then she found Natasha on Facebook
sent her a photo of her and the girls
just so she just said everything that
was happening she enjoyed leaving Eddie
and as so far she knows he's all alone
he pays child support and he visits
sometimes Oh like both wife's be married
twice though at that point I would just
let it be I would just be like you know
what he's taking he's paying and taking
care of both families just let it be at
this point they should have just been
more minutes she doesn't say that she
married he married Natasha it's just
that that was his partner
sounds like a spies name Natasha
it is like Widow oh that's right that's
right homie listen no like they're
together but just not married by law ah
domestic partnership wouldn't it bless
you hmm cuz he was already married tells
asking hardly married okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]